this next story is again pile this in
the same category of almost every story
we've covered today it's not surprising
but my god
Donald Trump is suggesting that protests
should be legal based on an interview
that he did with the extremely far right
and questionably racist Daily Caller
this is what the President had to say as
reported by The Washington Post I don't
know why they don't take care of a
situation like that referring to
protesters in the cabinet Ron hearings
Trump said I think it's embarrassing for
the country to allow protesters you
don't even know what the side the
protesters are on he added in the old
days we used to throw them out today I
guess they just keep screaming I mean
the key part in this entire statement is
you don't even know what side the
protesters are on because let's be sure
if the Republicans had somebody there
protesting on their behalf and they knew
thinking of lower Loomer and the
Missouri congressman if they know that
they were conservative I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty sure they'll be okay with it
but here's the thing I think we
discussed this yesterday with regard to
protests in general people in power
would never approve of your protest no
matter how you do it
no matter how you do it and there is
really very little incentive I mean
think about how ridiculous lower Loomer
looked if you haven't seen that clip go
click on a link somewhere and watch the
commentary that I just gave a Laura
Loomer trying to protest the the
Congress congressional hearing of Jack
Dorsey from Twitter and she looked
extremely ridiculous not only because
the congressman made a fool of her but
also because who are you protesting you
guys have the entire where all the reins
of power when you're protesting Congress
to do something about Jack Dorsey well
that's literally what they're doing
based on something that's not actually a
problem so you're getting what you
actually want but now you're making a
scene asking for more and that goes back
to the entire point that I'm trying to
say I guess something
you know it makes absolutely no sense if
you think about it people who have power
have no incentive or need to protest and
so the statement by Trump I know that
and I know there's absolutely no reason
to think intellectually about something
that Trump says but I'm going to try
anyway you don't even know what side the
protestors own you can guarantee that
nine times out of ten if not higher the
protesters are going to be on the side
of the disenfranchise of the
marginalized because they need an
opportunity to actually be heard and
because of that you know if Donald Trump
is suggesting that protests should be
illegal that it's going to have a
crackdown effect overwhelmingly without
question like a laser-like focus on
progressive ideas and marginalized
communities period and that's why it's a
statement like this is so dangerous
coming from the President of the United
States because of who it targets and if
I could just flip the script just a
little bit here this is what's so
frustrating about free speech absolutist
on the left because I haven't really
heard much from them about this this
statement from the President of the
United States is a real threat to
freedom of speech because he is speaking
it with the full force and the authority
of the federal government and that is
who we needed to be protected from in
the First Amendment it was written to
protect us from the government not from
corporations whether you like the fact
that that we have to abide by the terms
of service for big corporate overlords
or not that's besides the point the
point is who we had to be protected from
was the federal government and our local
and state governments and so the fact
that the President of the United States
is suggesting even remotely hinting at
something like this [ __ ] set off the
alarms of all of the free speech
absolutist who regularly take up for
Nazis and
more recently are taking up for Alex
Jones but they're not saying anything
about this and this maybe maybe maybe
I'm being too dramatic I mean I guess
we're all paid to be a little dramatic
but still it's a serious issue the
President of the United States with the
executive branch with the authority of
the federal government behind him
suggesting that protests should be done
away with and yet quiet on the set